joe rogan but recently he actually
it seems like he started up again so i
want to get you guys comments on that he
had a guest on
and we we've been kind of protesting
like hey joe we're out here why don't
you have uh
a muslim on at one point he had for raza
be on here and they had a great
discussion towards the end
uh but recently he had ayan the liar
and i think she changed her name and
there's a great documentary it's called
ayan
hurasi ali exposed where they actually
these are these are
non-muslims i believe in the netherlands
who actually did a documentary and they
went to verify the statements that she
was
she was saying and they exposed her for
being a liar
so he's bringing a liar on her on his
show and he's talk
they're talking about islam do you guys
know about this and what are your
comments
well you know ayann curtis has been
known for a long time she's been around
since a long time bottom line bro you
want to make money
you just leave islam and start writing a
book and start talking
smack about islam you get tons of people
supporting you
and it's been happening it's been
happening with so many people
um of course they have the the leeway to
say well i was a muslim
i mean i am from their culture i've gone
through this it's always the dance
and distress type of you know um you
know arguments
and people are willing to put their
money on that they love that type of
drama you know
not without my child princesses of
saudi arabia all these you go through
airports and you see these books in
these you know
these bookshops right there on the first
first display right with like these
nikabi women
running away from their oppressive
husbands leaving islam
blah blah blah i mean look man this is
nothing new
the the enemies of islam have been
using these kind of tactics for the
longest time um
sadly obviously these people give
platforms to
these because it brings a lot of
ignorant people the majority of the
world i would say
till today still that's why we're doing
what we're doing we're trying to bring
the real issues to the tables because
majority of the world is still
ignorant of islam they're still
following only media
islam drive by islam drive through islam
that's all they get from the news here
and there and
it's very easy with labels extremists
misogynist to just dismiss
anyone right so the world is upset with
religion this is the truth and they will
project those
those feelings on to islam the christian
war for example
a lot of the western countries now i
mean especially in europe they don't
identify as
believers anymore right they've had it
with religion with the church with
priests with all these things but when
they hear about islam
the problem is they oversimplify things
they well it's the same thing with islam
it's just another religion organize
religion we don't need this we want to
free ourselves from the shackles
of islam so that's why it makes our work
very difficult to reach
these people uh because they already
have these preconceived ideas
and they dismiss you without even
listening to you
right you're not important so it's just
sad that's what we're doing what we're
doing that we're trying to reach out to
ali this is an uh gabriel this is what
disturbs me is that you have someone
like joe
they've also banned hijabs on the beach
too right haven't they done that and
just to keep it fair and balanced to
bring on
an academic someone a muslim to talk but
imagine because you guys uh obviously
you've heard of joe rogan one of the top
podcasts out in the world
to be breaking into people's homes
mosques associations
whatever looking for islamist materials
of dawah
and they will try and put a stop to that
they'll try and police
literally what goes into people's minds
and comes out of their mouths
wow that seems very dangerous to me
and kovit made it possible but
he's into martial arts so imagine you're
have a person
you're bringing on who's built their
whole career on martial arts right
but this person is a fake a fake black
belt for example so now
this this woman the i i i in hershey
the liar ali i think she even changed
her name is
even they exposed her name was she
changed it was
um lie but the thing is here he's
bringing on someone whose whole career
is based
on a lie yeah do you find that odd
well the thing is you see sometimes
people are closet islamophobes
so when you're a islamophobe you know
when you come out it's gonna you're
gonna get a bit of a backlash so you're
like you know what i'll do is
um i'll be i'll be honest i'll be very
strong um
jordan peterson as well i have the great
privilege today of
talking with ayan jerzy ali
she's one of my heroes i guess that's
the case ever since i read her book
recently how many jobs done a video by
and uh joe rogan um
jordan peterson he does like we'll be
honest we'll be giving him the benefit
of doubt
but he's starting to sound like a close
islamophobe i'm so sorry and then
people that follow the more radical
version of the religion that wants to
convert people to
discuss it to acknowledge it and to
automatically classify
any discussion of it as islamophobic and
i've seen this labeled this this label
put on you
that you are islamophobic he's made
certain statements about islam which he
has no knowledge about
and then joe rogan invites this woman
the assertion that islam is a religion
of peace if they want to believe that
islam is a religion of peace let's let's
say it's a long let's come
let's do it along with him it's as if
he's saying you know what
why don't you say the things i can't let
me invite you that's what it is danny
i can't see it but i'm you're my guest
you know no one can say nothing you know
i invited a guest you know i didn't tell
her to say that
you know come on let's no let's not fall
around here it's very simple what you're
doing
you can invite anyone mohammed hijab
hamzazzo says there's so many people
that you can invite that could come and
talk about islam but that's not going to
be good for you you don't like that
so the thing is to invite people like
her who's an outright and she's alive
she's alive she lied about her whole
life whole story you know and she's
there coming and she's lying and saying
you know that she's talking about forced
uh that in islam that
we're allowed to you know she's talking
about dawah and you know we can force
people to accept
uh they have to accept islam by the
sword this is the biggest myth
ever you know there's specific verses in
the quran in sura verse 2 5 256
you know very clearly islam islam you
cannot force anyone to
their your religion it's simple the
expansion of the
islamic empire does not mean there was
forced conversions
yeah it's the the empire expanding
doesn't mean you know people being
forced to accept islam
you know so people have this thinking
that oh yeah islamic empire expanded and
they're
converting people by the swords it's not
like that it's as simple as that to you
your religion to me mine
i'm i can convey but i can't force and
we have many examples
we have many examples in history where
individuals could have forced
a slave where he um he he he said look
if only you accepted islam
you know et cetera so you have many
examples where people were given the
chance to accept islam
but yeah there's an outright liar and
yeah and in charleston hopefully she'll
debate mohammed hijab one day
uh she touched upon it gabrielle i don't
know if you want to touch punish ali she
in her talk with joe rogan she touched
upon and we
cover this all that i mean we've covered
this so many times but
she mentioned i believe the forced
marriage
honor killings you
as a as a young woman were going to be
forced into an arranged marriage and
this is what
made you flee and and head to europe and
wind up in holland correct that's
correct had he been
with us earlier he might have taken this
initiative to force me into marriage at
the age of 15
16 17.
you guys uh you get kind of like this is
like an old
old old record you know that just keeps
playing and you get you know
tired of hearing this these uh it goes
from someone being ignorant who just
certainly sincerely doesn't know but
then somebody who obviously
knows the truth and then even her uh
community there called her out on that
you know so what do you say for the for
the person who sincerely maybe just
uh bit on this and how would you respond
for this honor killing forced marriages
right right i think i think sincerity is
is the key here
and you can defer and you can have you
know issues whatever
whatever it is you know even with jordan
peterson you know
i was reading his book he's a smart guy
man you know
but he's really disappointing because he
should know better
on the academic approach of verifying
information he's an academician
right so he's being academically
dishonest in the statements that he's
making you're talking about jordan
peterson now this jordan peterson yeah
yeah i'm talking about drawing pieces
you just wanted to make that point right
because
he's very smart guys a very smart man
here you understand it's not enough to
just be smart
you have to be also honest okay and you
have to
if you're doing so much research you
know how how much
academic integrity is important and
checking verifying information
that is the whole you know foundation of
islam
hadith the science of verifying hadith
and knowledge and information is
based on reliability on
you know academic checking of who says
what who is this person are they
qualified to actually relay this
information
it's a huge huge science that what's the
objective
to just make sure that honesty is there
when you're passing on information right
why so that
obviously you're not gonna misguide
people with the wrong things with
uh this woman may allah guide her
obviously the enemies of islam have been
using these type of tactics from the
time of the prophet
and subhanallah i mean i was today i was
teaching a class on
the fifa and we were mentioning the
incident
of the person who came and asked the
prophet about the statement in the quran
this is how the you they used to refer
to humble people pious people
as for their ancestors and so on you
know we are being islam we're not
directly the sons of
israel and
islam and so on till today bro you'll
find this argument on the
answering islam website that oh uh
crossover didn't know
that you know who's whose sister is uh
aarons or
uh mary's or you know i mean it's just
ridiculous
so these all these uh forced marriages
for
conversions by the sword and so on
they keep it's been refuted it's been
academically
approached and shown and so on
and i'm not denying that there was in
the history of islam
in some cases no doubt certain rulers
and leaders who did force converse there
are some
okay there's no doubt about it it's not
that that's not the question the
question is does
islam preach that is that the
theory of islam this is what's the way
as to what some person did
in this century that century i mean that
you can point to every single
nation and religion there's always going
to be certain bad apples that
interpreted things and did things their
whole way
now you have the for example
you know the uh where the word assassin
comes from right
and how and was directed his
attacks towards them actually you know
but these were claiming to be muslims
who
right we're doing all kinds of evil
things people will do a lot of things
okay
bottom line is what does islam
preach what does quran what does the sun
not preach
this is what we ask the world to look at
all right
this is what we ask the world to look at
ali yeah no there's nothing i can really
add on there but it's just like you know
they just have to repeat the same cycle
you know we have a lot of people who we
deal with like
mohammed hijab who debate the guy called
rotten wood
uh and he just you know he just
destroyed them you know and the thing is
with these people
you need to understand they're
he was doomed to hell fire now when he
was doing to hellfire he asked even
though how rebellious he was and how he
shows
it shows how rebellious he believes is
in this instance and it shows how
merciful allah is
he asks allah he to allow him to the day
of judgment
to show like and and it's very bizarre
actually at least wants to prove allah
he said allah give me time so i can
prove you
wrong and um by showing that these
people the adam that you wanted me to
bow down to that these people are not
going to obey you
and it's very strange you know when you
when you when you go through that you
know mentality
so what it just shows you is that in
police is end going to the hell fire and
his main objective is to take
as many people there with him yeah as
many people there with him it's as
simple as that
and these people adopt the same method
as iblis you know christianity in the
west
is diminishing and literally by the
millions by the millions
people are waking up like the trinity
doesn't make sense there was a
christian unitarian um in in history i
can't remember his name
he said how much longer is the
muhammadans going to laugh at us with
this concept of the trinity
they're mocking us and we need to get
rid of it he understood the problem
but the christians what's happening is
that because they've seeing a lot of
people
in the west uh leaving um christianity
what people like this rotten wood guy
and his likes what they do is if you
realize even when we go to speaker's
corner
the christian missionaries there are not
talking about the bible anymore
they have left it's like when we go
there all they're doing is there's a
specific woman there
who screams for eight hours straight
when i speak his corner
insulting the prophet eight hours
straight and i'm thinking
there must be some kind of a gin inside
you to have the power to do that and
i remember my mother going off to see
witcher doctors so she's continuously
doing that and then we go to other
missionaries
all they're doing is talking about islam
they said this verse
and i'm thinking why do you not talk
about the good news the g you know the
the gospel jesus loves everybody
they have totally abundant their mission
their
objective is to cause people to leave
islam that's their main objective
it's as good as saying we're going to
the fire we want to take as many people
as we can and
this shows you the intellectual power of
islam
that intellectually we have um shown
people the the concept of the trinity
doesn't make sense
the bible is not reliable mark matthew
luke john and paul we don't know who
they are you know like you said we have
signs of hadith
we know a lot about a lot of companions
mark matthew luke and drug if
if you took the bible and these people
through the signs of hadith
you won't even have fabricated hadith to
be worse than that so the thing is
what's happening now is these people
sadly have turned towards hate
and people like jordan peterson and joe
rogan
they don't realize that their actions by
inviting a liar like that to their
podcast
is going to cause many more people who
are going to carry out attacks that
happen in new zealand
because people get scared oh this is
what islam is what a violent religion we
need to put a stop to this
this is the reason why i confronted
britain first
tommy robinson jada franzen i went after
them one by one because
i knew the actions are causing people to
die just as
much when i went after the al muhajiroun
and some of them i went after them
and to tell them to you know what you
guys are a point is madness
because it's the same thing with them
they go and preach innocent
silly people who want to belong and join
them carrier attacks in london bridge
we get the results of that we get the
backlash so the thing is this is what
they're doing and their main objective
is that you know
this is interesting because in their
discussion she talks about
the meccan period and medinan period
when she's talking to joe rogan
okay i'm sorry the fir the peaceful
muhammad is
not medina it is the peaceful muhammad
is mecca
so mecca is where he first came out and
so if he says
if if a muslim today says unto you your
religion unto me mine i'm tolerant all
of that you are invoking
mecca and it's interesting uh i think
gabriel you quoted an eye i don't know
if this this was the one
that um and then you have the whole
you know persecution you know you guys
many people don't know that that
the muslims were and still are the most
persecuted people you know on the planet
and you had at that time
they were persecuted tortured and then
when prophet muhammad when he had
peace be upon him the opportunity when
they conquered when they came back to
mecca where they were expelled i mean
people don't i don't know if joe rogan
knows this
the scenario if he can paint it imagine
like what they watch all these
uh people out there who come back after
they've been oppressed and they just
butcher everybody and people are like
rooting them on because there was an
injustice
that had been done to them but all this
you could just name all the
from the boycotting the torture et
cetera et cetera a list just goes
miles long of all the impression and
torture and everything that happened to
the muslims when prophet muhammad
came back and conquered mecca with an
army of 10 000 strong
i mean what happened from there you guys
uh fill in the blank i mean what did he
he
what would what would a normal commander
general you know
do to to the people but what actually
happened and then he came back to mecca
that's right right i mean yeah we have
to also understand
did he did did he did he like slaughter
uh 90
of the people what did he do what were
the famous words what were the famous
words brothers what was the famous words
when he came back into mecca
after all these years for joe rogan so
if he doesn't know this
no he said basically i tell you what uh
yusuf
ali's prophet joseph said to his family
to his brothers go for
you are free you know so he freed the
people
is it is it true he says spread the uh
food spread the peace
um this came this was when he entered
medina
yes there were six people they were
blacklisted when he entered mecca
they're supposed to be executed because
they're criminals
maybe sometimes again the muslims take a
very um
we don't want to appear weak either okay
we're not like just pacifists right
um no one should should misunderstand
and
take it for granted that no the muslims
have a very strong
uh background very strong history of
warriors and
you know because we sometimes appear you
know too pacifistic
but i think what ali is talking about
here is talking about crazy people just
taking things their own manners in their
own hands and just
doing targeting innocent people and
whatnot right because they don't
understand properly
the process of them was the most
balanced person the most balanced
general the most uh
merciful yet at the same time when he
had to put his foot down he knew how to
put his foot down
and the laws of islam are no joke you
know no doubt about it
but we need to understand context we
need to understand application
we need to understand how and what um
it's so strange and so hypocritical that
the world
recognizes the contribution of alexander
the great
or napoleon or any of the great generals
the roman generals you name them or
caesar and so on it's studied in
universities as civilization
yet when you talk about prophet muhammed
people are the biggest liars and the
biggest let me use the word bigots okay
because they love to use these words
and the biggest you know uh academically
dishonest people
uh look at the his life he is number one
i mean there's no doubt about it
uh not just because you know you know he
was he was ranked as number one and the
most influential
but when you look at the discussion to
why
is because he was so comprehensive in
his application of law
of virtues of morality
of bravery of a manhood of mercy
right he basically the process of
knowing knew exactly which skill to use
in which situation and i think this is
where most people don't know today
you know they want to do this at this
time and i want to do something
else at the wrong time and this is not
wisdom hickman is to put the right thing
in the right place at the right time at
the same time we're not apologetic we're
not
you know dumbing down islam we're not to
use ali's words you know sugar-coating
things
um you know we're academically
presenting islam to the world we're
saying islam is a solution islam has a
solution for criminals islam has a
solution for
lawfulness islam has a solution for
all the ills of society that
human you know society right now is
is sinking so deep into right i mean
the world is being led by so many
different systems and philosophies that
have nothing to do with islam
yet they have not solved the problems of
of
poverty they have not solved the
problems of
you know crime they have not solved the
problems that economics
and people are dying all over the world
starving no one cares but all they're
representing reporting is
all kinds of other things there are huge
problems people are depression
people are not doing well okay resources
are being consumed by a very small
percentage okay look it up look at the
research
look at you want to look at world health
organization we'll look at other stuff
not only what they see on the news
look at everything okay and then i'm
asking okay where's the solution
you guys are leading the world with
democracy and all your
western philosophy okay fine i mean
people are saying don't talk about this
yeah but why not why not if you look at
even within their political systems
and with them within their problems
there's huge
differences left the right all the
political parties within
there's always been a push and shot okay
so
why not everyone has the the right to to
speak and to at least
ask well where's where are the solutions
where are the solutions
ali before i ask you this next question
just uh for the audience i mean
they that documentary for the woman that
joe rogan brought on i and the liar
uh uh the kind of the
the few things just for people to know
is she had in fact been
living and this is one of the lies that
she was called out for was
she had in fact been living in kenya for
over 10 years
and has never been experienced a war in
her entire life okay
so this is one of them two was to the
contrary her brother aunt and former
husband all testified that she was
indeed present at her wedding which she
she lied that she wasn't uh another
third
in fact she uh talks about uh
not having established you know because
this is what her books everything's
written on but in fact
she had maintained close contact with
her family after asylum and also
later even met with her former husband
who she was saying she was petrified
scared
of running from uh and the list goes on
of lies but how do you because uh ali
you probably um
obviously have a lot of experience but
when you hear when you quote this verse
from the verbatim word of god almighty
allah the quran living miracle
for everybody joe rogan jordan peter
just read the book
and it's just it's it's amazing like
people can it's like someone who's good
at calculus and all these sciences but
then
they can't add up one plus one it's two
you'd be like what's wrong with these
people you know what i mean
so the same thing with jordan peters
it's good you brought him up uh gabriel
but another person and then you made a
great example these are like closet
islam haters you know hey and they bring
out people and let them speak for
themselves they're being both
you know instead of doing it for
themselves but there's this ayah verse
in the quran
chapter 60 verse 8 where it says god
almighty allah does not forbid you from
being kind and just towards those who do
not
fight you because of your your deen your
religion or expel you from your
homes loves those who do justice
when you share this what kind of
response do you get ali i think is uh
these people that we we confront likely
like you know the britain first be it
lauren
lauren southern actually she cheated the
u-turn she left the whole thing
you know and when me and mohammad hijab
went to the free
uh the freedom of speech talk for tommy
robinson and it was quite bizarre
to me i see it as a social experiment
when i went there because we went there
it was a freedom of speech for everybody
i thought okay if it's a freedom of
speech for everyone
i'm sure they won't mind me as a muslim
ali dawa are coming and when we went
there
if he let me speak it would have he
would have he would have made a good
point for his
uh um agenda he didn't because we were
surrounded by thugs and he was about to
be killed
so this shows you this freedom of speech
is absolute nonsense
and he didn't let me speak i went there
i said look i want you you know what
they said to him
if he goes we'll kill him if he goes on
stage we'll kill him and i was like well
okay what happened to freedom of speech
there so you can see the
absolute hypocrites um so coming back to
the question
whenever i approach them when we talk
about uh uh
montana verse eight you know allah does
not forbid you from being just
just and kind to those who did not fight
you based on your faith or kick you out
of your houses
allah only forbids you based on
basically those who are fighting you
oh they say this is abrogated i go okay
where is it obligated where
where is it obligated the thing is they
have a thinking process
and they know they're doing it for other
than the truth it's not the truth
they're doing it for gains
it's mainly financial so anything that
you bring that's going to dismantle that
is a direct threat to their purpose
so what they do is they call denial they
don't know they shall
they do all kinds of stuff to get out of
it so it's very clear the quran is very
clear that's why when i went to tommy
robinson
i asked him a very direct question can
you please show me a single verse in the
quran
that had the islamic literature in
history that tells us that we can go out
and kill innocent people
because they're disbelievers they're
also just because they are this
believers we can kill them
nothing zilch the guy asked him 20 times
in that one and a half hour and that was
my main purpose of
going to him because he had nothing he
knows that
islam does not teach this but if he
acknowledges that and he knows that this
is what
this this belief is that you hide the
truth
that's exactly what they do they know
it's a lie they know it's a lie they
know the truth is about they cover it
and that is the reason why the
punishment is so severe the hell fight
in the hereafter because you
know it's the truth you know you're
lying you know your actions and your
words that you're saying are going to
cause
a ripple effect like new zealand um
the attacks happen in christ church but
you would rather do that because you're
benefiting
and recently one of his um friends in
tom robinson
uh they came out that they were having
cocaine parties with these money that
were raising funds for
they were having cocaine parties you
know and these men
let me just tell you one thing as well
tommy robinson and there's one guy
this is a fact wait who was having coke
they were drunk
that's that white powder you put in your
nose huh who was who was doing
who was doing that that's verified he's
got a friend called dana white i
this is one of the number one islam
haters you're talking about in the world
right now
yeah one of his right hand right hand
men you can say yeah um is that he was
having an affair with another woman
and they were saying basically they were
having cocaine parties and one of
uh the the people that were working with
tommy robinson his name was
um kanan robertson i had an interview
with him he he stopped working with
tommy robinson after me and hijab got
attacked because he said look
that day i realized that this is this is
hypocrisy tommy robin is not about
freedom of speech
he just doesn't like islam i had an
interview with him he was telling me
this he goes look
the money that they were raising they
were having like cocaine party
cocaine parties and all this kind of
stuff with the money where's tommy
robinson getting all these funds from
i don't understand this guy owns a
million pound house where was again
recently just uh filed bankruptcy
yeah because there's a law a lawsuit um
because he um slandered this um syrian
refugee
so the thing is most of these people
they're absolutely hypocrites they come
tommy robinson
uh even this this friend that danny
daniel what is called
um jada franzen paul golding avi yemeni
these people you know they would always
come to me and talk about a woman being
abused in islam
do you know avi yemeni in australia
there's he's a like a
proper zionist yeah he threw a um you
know cutting chopping board
yeah he threw that at his wife tommy
robinson once was caught
on the in the public by an undercover
officer abusing his wife
paul golding paul golden you know paul
gold in britain first paul golding and
jaded friends and that woman with the
red hair
do you know there was a documentary paul
golding is that is that one of the
women that was trying to uh uh shake
your hand
and then you is that the one yeah yes
you know that one she
keeps talking about women's right yeah
you know paul golding that guy
he she was with he would lock her up in
a room
and beat her up did you know that
did you know no he would lock her up in
a room and be her up and she had the
audacity to come to me and say to me
shake my hand and i said with respect i
don't know why why aren't you
gonna get my main point let me tell you
if you think that because we're
christians and i'm holding this cross
that you can come here you can lie in
our faces
and that you can attack our people
but her boyfriend was putting his hands
on her in a illegal way but she was too
busy
she was making a big deal because i
didn't shake her hand in a way of
respect i didn't want to touch her
and she had a big fuss about it but
behind closed doors
her her boyfriend paul golding was
beating her up physically putting her
hands on her and literally beating her
up and looking
in rooms this is the hypocrisy all of
them are wife peters
wow okay well before we go before we go
on and move on we spent a lot on this so
just
because we know that islam is the the
same way of life that jesus lived moses
lived the last fight of mr prophet
muhammad that call for the human being
to acknowledge that there's one and only
one creator of the heavens and earth
and he sent messenger and that simple
message is to worship the creator the
one and only
and to be morally upright is a simple
message so if jordan peterson
if joe rogan uh i and her ayan the liar
horsey
ali any of them if they turned their
life
around and they wanted to you know uh
rectify their affairs and
you know they had a you know they had a
moment that they realized that
okay what's the true purpose of life you
know and they look at the evidence if
they just look at the evidence the
preservation of the quran if they look
at the signs that are in there the
prophecies the miracles if they look at
the life of prophet muhammad sincerely
you know from the proper lenses and they
like most people you know when they do
they accept this is the truth
you know what would you guys say to them
now like if you had a chance to sit with
them just quickly what would you say to
to these three individuals
well i would say i mean obviously they
they uh they read the purana if they
just
open their eyes and their hearts
yeah i'll give them to him yeah i mean
that's the best thing
for them you know and then subhanallah
once they uh embrace islam
and muslims are gone they're brothers
and sisters what translation because you
know they're orientalists if they pick
up you know there's been deliberate
attempts by some orientalists to go
ahead and translate the quran so if they
get a hold of one of these
which which uh clear quran sahih
international what what uh
what i think uh you know the
international
or the uh quran project you know.org
so pick up the quran read it all right
instead of talking about it read the
book i want to say read ali what would
you say to them to joe rogan
our friend joe rogan who's uh who's
actually
yeah same you know same thing you know
yeah like you know then they look if you
want to judge a book
you know or judge me one you know
imagine imagine
you're you're learning about someone
imagine me learning about joe rogan
or jordan peterson i don't i don't watch
any of the videos i don't watch his
podcast
i just go and learn about him from
someone that doesn't like him imagine i
invite him and i say you know tell me a
bit about joe rogan oh joe rogan's a
woman abuser oh
where's her what what an evil guy you
know and then how is that would that be
fair
how would joe rogan feel and draw the
jordan pieces will feel few like they'll
be so angry they're like ali you could
have come to me and speak to me
and you're here inviting people that
dislike me and you're learning
you're getting to know me via someone
that doesn't like me how is that fair
but i'm asking you the same question
jordan peterson and joe rogan how is
that fair that you're getting to know
the quran
via people that don't like it and then
you are and you're
and you have these emotional feelings
and be like oh this is this can't be
from god
well how can i blame you in the context
well i can't blame you
because you're getting to know a
scripture not for yourself but via the
enemies
you wouldn't like it for yourself so
don't do it to us beautiful